[Music]
for black women the story of voting
rights
is a long one
very early on at the dawn of the 19th
century
they are already at work on a political
philosophy that decries racism and
sexism in american politics
but constitutionally speaking it begins
with the 15th amendment because black
women also need
race to be an impermissible criteria
if they're to get to the polls sojourner
truth is a name
people might know the former slave
anti-slavery activist and women's rights
activist
francis ellen watkins harper poet
anti-slavery lecturer
we also have figures like nanny helen
burrows
id wells was another major activist that
people don't necessarily associate
with the suffrage movement but she
absolutely was
black women never find a very
comfortable home in women's suffrage
associations racism is always
present sometimes in very pronounced
ways
we have pictures of parades marches
women dressed up
in sort of late 19th early 20th century
victorian
gear hats large hats carrying signs
about votes for women
and most of these images are of white
women
the key figures are a remarkable
duo of women elizabeth katie stanton
and susan b anthony and those two women
will take us to the 19th amendment
in august of 1920 the state of tennessee
will by a mere one vote ratify the 19th
amendment an amendment that prohibits
the states from using
sex as a criteria for voting and it will
become part of the constitution
and american women win the right to vote
so for white woman it was the end of a
long fight but for many black women it
was just the beginning of an uphill
battle to exercise those rights
african-american women are aware but
really everyone is aware
that nothing in the 19th amendment is
going to prohibit
individual states from continuing to
disenfranchise
black voters and so the first election
that they had after the bill passed
the white women were going to vote and
we'd just step and went to vote
and when we got on there well we
couldn't vote
they gave us all different kind of
excuses why
we just stayed we stayed we asked we
wanted to know why we couldn't vote and
the
answers to the questions were so invalid
we were not satisfied
so finally one woman mrs simmons said
are you saying that we can't vote
because we're negros
and he said yes negroes don't vote in
primary in texas
so that just hurt our hearts real bad
and so the 19th amendment even as we
mark this
anniversary it leaves many many american
women
to continue the struggle for political
rights including the vote
and african-american women are one
chapter or one facet of that story
there's nothing in the 19th amendment
that guarantees chinese
immigrant women the vote there's nothing
in the 19th amendment that guarantees to
native american
women the vote latinx women particularly
mexican-american women
also occupy an ambiguous place
in the story of voting rights
for black women the right to vote is
symbolic
and that's not to diminish symbolism
it's to say
that the right to vote is a sign that
they are
full and equal citizens of the united
states
african-american women are facing the
challenges
of racial violence lynching and
access to the polls african-american
women are looking at a range
of inequalities economic inequalities
housing inequalities health inequalities
educational inequalities and access
to the ballot is a lever in those
struggles
it is the gateway to sitting on juries
it is the gateway to office holding
black women have an agenda and it is an
ambitious one
and one that they hope the vote will
help them
further it wasn't easy
to try to get people to come out to go
and try to register to vote because
the first time that we went we had a
circle around the courthouse
of pickup trucks and rifles
and white people getting ready to stop
us only four people got in that whole
day
what did the white people have to fear
from somebody blacks registering if they
became a registered voter
many of the blacks would seek positions
in the political field they would be out
they would fight for justice if they
were
registered voters they would turn the
city completely around
and that is the reason why they did not
want to see black people become
registered voters what black women want
in the wake of the 19th amendment
is federal legislation that will now
protect
their voting rights to impose on those
states with a history
of disenfranchising black voters an
extra requirement
and black women will wage a campaign
that will take them
all the way to 1965 and passage
of the voting rights act in that year
it's important to say
that winning the voting rights act is a
brutal brutal campaign black americans
women and men put their lives on the
line
in too many southern jurisdictions in
order to
force the hand of congress
to force the hand of lyndon johnson
to win voting rights legislation
this is not an easy road for
african-american
women it is a harrowing road but it is
indeed a victory one that black women
had been looking for
for nearly half a century
[Music]
i know that my grandmother raised my
mother that they always had to vote
like it was something that she was born
in my grandmother
susie jones her portrait hangs on the
wall and i am very accountable to her
even as she passed many years ago
people ask me why do we need to know
this history
today we live in an era of voter
suppression
laws that are neutral on their face
voter id
requirements or the purging of voter
rolls
or the shuttering of polling places none
of which
announce that they are aimed at keeping
voters of color women of color from the
polls
but when we look at those laws in
practice we can recognize that like
in 1920 in 2020
seemingly neutral laws are being used to
disproportionately keep people of color
away from the polls
by running for political office and
affecting
change on the ground in their
communities and in their states so we
now have black women
running for governorships and we have a
number of african-americans that we've
seen
has shaped elections so i think the idea
of enfranchisement is also expanded to
not just being able to vote
but exercising political power and
exercising political agency and i think
that's the legacy
of the suffrage movement to me these are
not women who dropped out of the sky
these are women who come out of a
political tradition and are building
upon that and will tell you that
if you ask them these women and the
generations
that followed worked to make democracy
and opportunity real in the lives of
all of us who followed
you